if you could remake any disney movie
into a live-action film
which stars would you choose to play
your favorite characters
are you really queen of arendelle i am
we might have tons of live-action disney
remakes from cinderella to fairy tale
reimaginings like mirror mirror but if
we were in the casting chair
we might be tempted to cast some of
these celebrities who look just like
disney characters without even trying
from chris hemsworth as a potential
tarzan to the sass and confidence
rihanna would bring as princess tiana
here are some stars who would be amazing
as our favorite disney darlings
it's like a dream a wonderful dream come
true
elizabeth olsen has already proven she's
one of the toughest actresses out there
who else would make the perfect jane
porter she's got the classic brown hair
down
we know she can rock some early 1900s
fashion while acing an english accent
who's sweating are we going to and she's
used to doing her own stunts we could
definitely imagine her swinging from
vines with her jungle boy love interest
speaking of tarzan another marvel actor
might be the perfect choice for the
monkey loving man who falls head over
heels for jane
chris hemsworth has proven he can pull
off long flowy hair and he's switched
physique so many times that he could
definitely
become the lean but strong jungle
dweller who saves his family from
poachers
you came back plus don't you want to see
him in a loincloth
the olsen twins haven't been acting for
a while but we could just imagine them
starring as live-action versions of elsa
and anna back when they appeared in
movies like new york minute
the twins have always been scene
stealers and trust me she would have won
this thing hands down
and with the right styling some icy
blonde locks and a bright red braid
they would make the perfect pair of
sisters trying to save arendelle
we've always wanted to see the olsen
twins as disney princesses
lily cole is a pretty famous model and
also a fan favorite casting choice to
play the reluctant disney princess
merida her signature red hair is perfect
for the rebellious character and she
would look lovely in emerald green we're
not sure if she has any archery skills
but we're sure she can manage it well
enough like jayla did as katniss but
there's one thing we're curious about
can the english model pull off a
scottish accent
and is roaming the wilds waiting his
chance of revenge
anne hathaway is used to playing royalty
we've even kind of seen her as a disney
princess
when she played the cinderella inspired
ella in ella enchanted but the role
we'd really like to see her in is belle
from beauty and the beast
anne hathaway looks like she could have
her face stuck in a book all day
far away in fair verona and still make
it to the ball by eight
plus we'd love to hear her belt out bell
while walking through the streets of
small town france and use her wits to
put the arrogant gaston
in his place you are positively primeval
amanda seyfried would make the perfect
rapunzel the blonde hair
definitely has something to do with it
but amanda also has a kind face
and some excellent comedic acting chops
so if you're from africa
why are you white she would give flynn
riders wits a run for their money and
she also has the voice of an angel
we could imagine her sitting high in her
tower longingly belting out
when will my life begin there is really
only one choice for who we would get to
play cinderella in a new live-action
movie
and that's zendaya the actress was once
a disney channel star and she's already
dressed up as the iconic princess
complete with special effects zendaya
doesn't have to bippity boppity boop
herself into looking like a princess
since she already does and can't you
easily imagine her making friends with
all the birds and mice at her wicked
stepmother's house
what's all the fuss about your mouse in
the house brand new
rapunzel isn't the only headstrong
character from tangled
and an actor with great comedic skills
is a must for the rebellious flynn rider
jake gyllenhaal would be perfect for the
role he's handsome
funny and great at stunts so he would
make a terrific swashbuckler trying to
evade capture
and get rapunzel back to her kingdom
plus we'd love to see jake's reaction to
getting hit in the face with a frying
pan
[Music]
the live-action little mermaid is
already in production with pop star
halle bailey as ariel but who would make
the perfect prince eric
we think cole sprouse would be great for
the role he can pull off the dark hair
and we feel like he'd capture the
essence of a prince who wants to fall in
love with a normal girl
he showed off his skills as a love
interest and five feet apart and he's
probably the most desirable bachelor on
tv
right now so there's definitely prince
eric potential
you're not wrong you think that's cute
do you think it's cute
if cole sprouse is our romantic lead who
would make the perfect underwater
villain
we think angelina jolie could bring her
sinister smile to the role of ursula
imagine her in ursula's iconic purple
with eels swimming hungrily around her
plus she looks exactly like the evil
sorceress turned human when she tries to
trick eric into marrying her if angelina
can give us creepy witch vibes as
maleficent then she could definitely
capture the horrific persona of the
iconic sea witch
not a chance triton she's mine now some
of lucy hale's looks and pretty little
liars complete with the short dark hair
have got to be inspired by snow white
lucy starred in a cinderella inspired
movie but we can't believe she hasn't
had her chance to play a disney princess
yet she can act sing
and dance and if she threw on a ball
gown and wandered through the forest
we're pretty sure she'd find herself
being followed by all kinds of curious
animals
whoever plays princess tiana has got to
have a lot of sass
and the voice of an angel so how about
rihanna she's dressed like a disney
princess before
and pulls it off every time and we can
imagine her taking on the role of a
hard-working waitress who dreams of
owning her own restaurant
rihanna also loves to cook and she
worked her way from barbados
to hollywood so she'd probably be
inspired by tiana's enchanting tale
don't you worry daddy we'll be there
soon
imagine l woods but instead she's
tinkerbell it's
perfect right reese witherspoon is a
sassy blonde bombshell and she would
make an
excellent little fairy as elle woods she
proved that she can be cute and smart
and she saves the day more than once she
would make the perfect pal for peter pan
and can you just imagine the incredible
fashion the fairy would get to wear
in a live-action remake pinocchio is a
kid but we can't help think that glee
star chris colfer would make an
excellent casting choice for the boy
that's not a boy
perhaps the live-action remake would
find pinocchio a little older and trying
to become a real boy so he can
experience high school and make friends
outside of geppetto's workshop
plus chris colfer can really sing so he
would make an excellent addition to a
pinocchio musical
mr shu i've prepared a number for the
occasion
of course kurt disney's hercules is kind
of underrated but a live-action remake
should definitely cast
megan fox in the role of sassy megura
she has meg's striking features and
could pull off her cynical attitude
while
also highlighting her softer side megan
would look stunning with meg's
red hair and greek fashions plus her
transformers stunt skills would be put
to good use when she saves hercules from
certain doom you didn't have to people
always do crazy things
as for hades we would need a real-life
trickster who can pull off arrogance
comedy and burning anger tom hiddleston
already has experience
playing a manipulative character as loki
in the marvel cinematic universe
we could imagine him with blue skin and
fiery blue hair
he would come off as both hilarious and
terrifying
the perfect mix for the eccentric ruler
of the underworld
is this kid gonna mess up my hostile
takeover bit or what what do you think
just for the sake of trying something
new we won't go with dwayne johnson to
play maui even though we are sure he'd
be excellent
instead what about jason momoa as the
troublesome demigod he's definitely got
the physique and can pull off the hair
and tattoos
as for moana we couldn't see anyone in
the role but au li'i
provalu they look so alike that it's
hard to believe moana's character design
wasn't based on the fresh-faced actress
my people didn't send me
the ocean did a live-action alice in
wonderland has already been done but
wouldn't lily reinhardt make the perfect
alice
like her character in riverdale lily can
be both youthful and innocent as well as
strong
and resilient we could imagine her
joining the mad hatter for a tea party
and taking on the dreaded queen of
hearts
your majesty indeed why you're not a
queen
anastasia isn't 100 a disney movie but
we had to mention how much scarlett
johansson would rock as anya
the oscar-nominated actress would be
amazing as an orphan
suffering from amnesia as she tries to
find her way back home and figure out
who she really is
scarlett is excellent in period pieces
and she could probably bring a
live-action anastasia to a potential
oscar-winning territory
billy eilish is up and coming so maybe
she'll soon try her hand at acting
and we've got the perfect role for her
she would be awesome as the troubled and
tormented princess keita from
atlantis the lost empire as she tries to
remember her past and rediscover her
lost kingdom plus
atlantis doesn't get enough credit and
it's about time we finally got a
live-action remake
i only wish there was more we could do
for you which of our casting choices
is your favorite let us know which stars
you'd pick instead in the comments
section below
don't forget to hit that like button if
you enjoyed this video and subscribe to
the things for more thanks for watching
and we'll see you next time